Mr fetterman I do have a specific  question which you can continue on this  topic but you have made two conflicting  statements regarding fracking in a 2018  interview you said quote I don't support  fracking at all I never have but earlier  this month you told an interviewer quote  I support fracking I support the energy  Independence that we should have here in  the United States so Mr fetterman please  explain your changing position 67. good  question and good job by her I've I've  always supported fracking and I always  wanted  our energy is is critical and we can't  be held you know you know Ransom to  somebody like Russia you know I've  always believed that energy Independence  is critical and I've always believed  that and I do support fracking I've  never taken any money from their their  their industry but I support how  critical it is that we produce our own  energy and create energy Independence